the super bowl as mentioned is coming up
in just four days one of the injury
issues that didn't get as much attention
because patrick mahomes had a concussion
was that toe on which he obviously was
hobbling in the divisional round game
against the cleveland browns mahomes
played
in the afc championship against the
bills looked fine no issues he met with
reporters yesterday and provided an
update on that tow that continues to get
back to full strength here he is
it feels a lot better i mean having
these two weeks to let it rest and heal
up
especially being almost three weeks away
from the
over three weeks away from the uh the
injury itself i mean if you look at
those type of injuries that kind of
gives you the normal timeline so uh
definitely every single day that i get
arrested it makes it even better um but
it's it's pretty close to 100 and i'm
sure by game day it will be
that's good news for the chiefs bad news
for the bucks because they're going to
need him to be fully mobile to be able
to run around at full speed to have no
impairment no limitation but i was
impressed thinking back to that browns
chiefs game when he was
he was hobbled between plays yes and he
was fine
during the play right i mean no
noticeably uncomfortable right in
between plays to where you could see the
look on his face and there was a little
bit of like a permanent grimace to be
like wow this is radiating through my
whole body you know right from my big
toe uh it is a very annoying injury as
we've talked about but i think like like
you just said mike i mean his movement
is key to the super bowl it's key to his
success the team's success we know about
the offensive line issues right so part
of their part of their way hey one okay
offensive line issues we know how great
he is is scrambling and making people
miss and move and do doing all those
things but it's become part of their
game plan as we've talked about all
those sprint out passes and everything
like that plus
with a super bowl defense like the bucks
who
you know is gonna have that 2007 giants
mentality that hey the front four we got
to get there or we can't win the
football game
um yeah this is you know not what they
want to hear because the difference
between that 2007 tom brady new york
giants football game is you knew where
tom brady was going to be that's the
greatness of patrick mahomes you can get
pressure on him and feel like you never
get close to him because he makes people
miss and then throws completions down
the field so it's good to hear for him
for sure
and we've talked about this before that
condition turf toe it sounds so
innocuous i remember the first time i
ever heard a guy had it it was franco
harris in the 70s and i remember
thinking turf toe that doesn't sound
very bad why can't he play with turf toe
but it's a spraining of the ligaments in
that big toe it's extremely painful and
you think about it just go walk around
get up and take a walk right now yeah
you push off your weight on that big toe
as you move and if those ligaments are
sprained you've got a problem especially
if you're trying to run around full
speed in in those football shoes that
are uh tight and uncomfortable he wore a
larger cleat in the afc championship and
had some extra padding in there we'll
see whether or not he needs that on
sunday but it sounds like he's getting
to where he needs to be which again is
very good news for the chiefs not very
good news for the buccaneers also good
news for the chiefs sammy watkins a guy
who
i mean let's face it you can't count on
it no he can't stay healthy but last
year in the super bowl he had a big
impact ran by richard sherman made a big
catch helped the effort to take the lead
late in the game sammy watkins
gave an update on his injury status with
the calf problem that has kept him out
of action here he is from yesterday
um feeling great um but i'm still
working out with the training staff for
ray
um and just going over everything so i
can have a chance and possibly you know
go out there and fill 100
or 95 or 85 wherever i get at um by
sunday but feeling pretty good very
optimistic um having good practices so
i'm hopeful i can go out there and have
fun and play
well he's going to be out there even at
85 percent that's what you do though
when you're in the last game of your
contract and you got to do something to
get someone's attention it's gonna be
very difficult for free agents coming up
in 2021 not the big name guys the
mid-level guys the salary cap going down
the stars are still going to get their
money the rookies are still going to get
their money because it's all
predetermined it's a formula based upon
where you're drafted the guys in the
middle are going to get squeezed as the
cap drops and i think sammy watkins is
going to be one of these guys in the
middle who gets squeezed now if he comes
out and has a huge performance in the
super bowl maybe he doesn't get squeezed
he's got a lot riding on number one his
ability to play chris and number two his
ability to play well in that game well
definitely i mean you know first off
sammy watkins in a lot of ways i feel
bad for him because he's a superstar
talent who
we we've talked about these things right
before mike i mean he had a foot injury
coming out of college his rookie year
there and he's had lower leg injuries
ever since it's like it's never been
quite a hundred percent to where you
just go we don't have to worry about
injuries anymore but to your point
and like the importance of the football
game and what he does for this football
team to me i mean of course we know
sammy watkins makes their team better
yes i mean he's a specimen he's the kind
of guy that i don't care what corner you
are you got to respect him he can scare
you he can catch a slant or run by you
for 50 yard bombs and do things like
that you know so that's where you know
it's important and and the the other
importance to me mike at least is the
chiefs are at their best when
i feel it's mahomes in the shotgun you
know kelsey and hill here over here
split out to the right and now we got
mccole hardman and sammy watkins to the
left when you have those four on the
field with whatever running back
that is a game changer because it really
puts a defense in a tough position it's
hard to play bl it's hard to blitz and
play man-to-man with that many speedy
guys split out to where you go i don't
know if we have four guys that can match
up with them and
just one thing i know we talked about it
last year
we haven't hit it as much this year like
but the chiefs are much better football
team more dangerous than sammy watkins
on the field so that's good good news
for them in their offense
and this gets back to that dedication
the chiefs have
to continue loading the cannon with fast
guys second round pick on me call
hardman now at the time they made that
pick tyree kill was at the front end of
right something that ended up working
out for him but at the time it seemed
very ominous and foreboding but it did
work out they have me called hardman
they have tyree kill they have
semi-watkins
and watkins re-did his deal last year
right he got squeezed last year the
chiefs right yeah and he hits the market
this year he's he's there's a bunch of
guys throughout the league and this has
yet to set in for the fans and i hope
it's starting to set in for the players
just so they're ready for it this drop
in the salary cap that money is coming
from somewhere and it's going to come
from the mid-level veteran-free agent
guys with recognizable names right not
superstars they're gonna get squeezed
someone told me when we were discussing
this not long ago a guy like in
dominicans who got eight million from
the bucks in 2020 that is going to be
more like 3 million in 2021 same type of
player same type of need same type of
market but
because that cap space is going to
disappear to the tune of 19.8 million
per team no 18.2 million per team sorry
that is a lot now that's expected to be
the the drop they don't know for sure
and they won't know for sure until maybe
hours before the new league year begins
but there's going to be guys who get
squeezed very badly buccaneers players
all participated in the tuesday walk
through practice that the team had but
there are
four guys
who are not ready to go three three key
guys who are not ready to go antonio
brown
jordan whitehead and antoine winfield
there's also questions about lavonte
david and jpp but it was brown who was
unable and we knew he would be unable to
play in the nfc championship it was
antoine winfield jr who had an injury
late in the practice week before the
game against the packers right and
ultimately was kind of a surprise
scratch on game day and then it was
jordan whitehead who suffered a shoulder
injury in the game and left those three
guys we don't know what's gonna happen
with them and those guys in the back end
of the secondary chris oh my gosh how
critical they're gonna be to trying to
slow down the chief's offense yeah with
all the issues they had the first time
around and really i mean they held up
mahomes and company i think what was the
number that day 462 yards it could have
easily
easily been over 550 i mean it really
could have mahomes missed some plays
they missed some plays all together so
yeah you're exactly right they need
those guys in the secondary they need
them too to just mix and match personnel
rest guys hey you know let's get a fresh
body in but two they'll have their own
you know certain matchups where okay
it's you know second and five we want to
play a lot of dbs in the game but we
need the extra safeties here because
they might run the ball or do something
like that that's where they're going to
miss these guys a lot as far as antoine
winfield and whitehead they need them
they're tacklers they're pretty good
coverage pretty good range as far as
pass games concerned i mean so that that
is that's a big deal
the the levante david jpp thing would be
huge but i don't get the sense that
that's like a real concern right mike or
like a real
thing that they could miss the football
game it's just kind of like maintenance
and they're not a hundred percent we're
taking care of them right now
david's got a hamstring injury which
requires above all else rest and time
and i didn't practice at all
last week also jpp and i'm looking at
the report here of course that's the
chief so that's not going to tell me
anything jpp has a knee yeah and he was
given the this is strange he got the
designation all three days last week did
not practice because of knee
and then comma not injury related which
is one of those strange things about the
nfl injury report so it was kind of his
knee but it was also a kind of rest so
it's not just the knee right
we want to rest him but he's getting
treatment on his knee yeah i think
that's the only way you can harmonize
those two we deliberately gave him those
three days off but he's getting
treatment on his knee right i think
he'll practice this week yes but you do
have to be concerned about the levante
david hamstring and i'm looking down
here on the injury report pete i don't
know where's this levante david
hamstring coming from because i'm and
all i see is antonio brown jpp antoine
winfield and uh
uh
i see limited participation from jordan
whitehead um i don't know i don't know
when the levante david thing happened
we're gonna have to check on that a
little bit more but apparently he's got
a hamstring problem that becomes a
potential issue
he tweaked it in the nfc championship
but again as i look at the
as am i looking at the right week never
mind well either way listen and that and
like
look listen i will fully admit as i did
the quick search for buccaneers injury
report in my email
it pulled up the uh conference
championship injury report which would
not be the correct one
see if you want the super bowl injury
report you have to get the right one and
now i have the right one so forget
everything i just said last week it was
indeed antonio brown levante david jpp
jordan whitehead antoine winfield not
practicing and for pierre paul it was
knee not injury related on top of it and
for david it was hamstring so pete
you're right i'm wrong save it let it go
it's the only time it's ever gonna
happen
he got you definitely but yeah those are
concerning i mean we know that i mean we
know hey pass rush coverage is gonna be
a huge part of the game you know the
bucks that first time around
yes could they have won the game
certainly but it's it was a crazy game
could i also sit here and go yeah the
bucks had a chance to win i could also
sit here and go the kansas city chiefs
had a chance to win the game 45 to 10
and absolutely blow them out of the door
it's it's 17-0 they're on the eight yard
line going into score mahomes loses his
awareness a little bit of shaquille
barrett behind him is very rare where he
gets strip sack fumbled i mean that was
it was about to be ball game right there
so that's where the game is really
intriguing that's where the bucks need
to be
totally at a hundred percent they're
going to have to play their best game of
the season to beat this football team
because i expect the chiefs hey big
lights big games they just continue to
get better and better and i think you're
gonna see the chiefs play at a very high
level and really try to take advantage
of this opportunity of being
back-to-back super bowl champion
championship winners
yeah and that's why i'm so
flummoxed by this one because it could
be a blowout by the chiefs you have to
take the [ __ ] 70s
i have to yes i took the chiefs you took
the bucks before the year that's the way
it's going to go we're going down with
our teams
shireen williams yesterday on pft pm
gave me the license to change my mind
because it was so long ago
and a lot's happened since then oh and i
can't but i can't i can't i can't do it
i i'll text serene tomorrow if i have to
work or not i didn't know she was the
new boss i'll see i'll get i'll get no
no no she i i just i because we it came
up last night when we were trying to
fill frankly at the end of the show the
idea that i had uh uh already
pre-selected the buccaneers to win the
super bowl before the season began and
my team
that i picked to win the super bowl of
all the years i've been doing this has
never actually been in the super bowl so
i feel like i can't get off that horse
now even though yeah see there's a hedge
to be had there's a way i can do it
where i can still hedge and i'm trying
to hedge because i really do think that
the chiefs have a good chance to win but
i'm probably going to go all in with the
bucks by the time it's all
said and done
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports